>>> ALL RIGHT.
I PUT ALL THE FOOD AWAY, AND NOW
MY KITCHEN IS CLEAN.
PLEASE NOBODY GO IN THERE AND
MESS IT UP.
>> YES, MOM.
>> NOW, WHAT ARE YOU ALL
WATCHING?
>> SOME OLD HOME MOVIES?
>> WAIT, WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> HEY, KIDS, IT'S ME, DADDY.
IF YOU'RE WATCHING THIS, THAT
MEANS I'M ALREADY DEAD.
>> WHAT?
WHERE'S DAD?
>> HE'S UPSTAIRS ON THE TOILET.
>> WHERE DID YOU FIND THIS TAPE?
>> NOW I HID THIS TAPE IN A BOX
LABELED "FOOTBALL HIGHLIGHTS" SO
YOUR MAMA WOULDN'T WATCH IT.
THERE'S SO MUCH THAT I WANT TO
TELL YOU KIDS.
MAYBE WE SHOULD TURN THIS OFF.
>> SHH, I WANT TO HEAR THIS.
>> OKAY, SO BY NOW THE LAWYERS
HAVE PROBABLY INFORMED YOU THAT
I AM FLAT BROKE.
>> BROKE?
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED TO OUR
SAVINGS?
>> I WAS TOO EMBARRASSED TO SAY
ANYTHING.
NO MAN WANTS TO HAVE TO TELL HIS
FAMILY, "I BLEW MY WHOLE
RETIREMENT ON JB SMOOVE'S NEW
SPORT BETTING APP."
>> ALREADY?
I JUST DOWNLOADED THAT FROM HIM
LAST WEEK.
>> WALTER, GET IN HERE!
>> NO, MOM, WE CAN'T LET DADDY
KNOW WE SAW THIS.
IT WILL EMBARRASS HIM.
>> AYE, NOW, DON'T WORRY ABOUT
MY FUNERAL.
>> ALL YOU GOT TO DO IS PAY FOR
IT.
>> NO IDEA WHAT TOOK ME OUT.
COULD HAVE BEEN THE RONA,
MAYBE BECAUSE I HAVEN'T HAD A
GLASS OF WATER SINCE 2003.
COULD HAVE BEEN JB SMOOVE COMING
TO COLLECT.
[ TOILET FLUSHING ]
>> IS THAT A TOILET?
>> TURN THIS OFF.
DAD MUST BE COMING DOWN.
>> THAT WAS -- THAT WAS ONLY HIS
FIRST FLUSH, WE GOT ABOUT
20 MINUTES.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT ELSE, WHAT
ELSE?
OH, I ALSO HAVE A SECRET
DAUGHTER.
SHE PROBABLY BE AT MY FUNERAL
>> NO, NO, NO.
IT'S NOT HOW YOU THINK.
I WOULD NEVER CHEAT ON YOUR
MOTHER RAW.
>> EWW.
>> TRUTH IS, I WAS A SPERM DONOR
BACK IN THE DAY.
YEAH, BUT I NEVER WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT HAD I KNOWN THAT THEY
WAS GOING TO USE IT TO MAKE
BABIES.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK THEY WERE
GOING TO USE IT FOR?
[ TOILET FLUSHING ]
>> AND TO MY ONLY SON,
WALTER JR.
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR PASSING
DOWN THE ERECTILE DYSFUNCTION.
>> EWW!
>> WHAT?
I DON'T HAVE THAT.
>> YOU MAY NOT HAVE IT RIGHT
NOW.
BUT YOU DEFINITELY WILL.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE MY SON,
YOU UNDERSTAND?
SO I'M LEAVING YOU THIS HERE
SPECIAL PUMP.
I PUT THE GOOGLY EYES SO IT SO
THE GIRLS WON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
NOW -- IT MAY NOT GET YOU ALL
THE WAY THERE.
BUT CERTAINLY, IT WILL GET YOU
CLOSE ENOUGH.
>> CAN YOU FAST FORWARD PAST
THIS PART?
>> LOOK.
MAYBE I WASN'T THE BEST DAD.
OR THE BEST HUSBAND.
BUT I WANT YOU KIDS TO KNOW I
TRIED MY VERY BEST.
TO WRITE THE GREATEST CRIME
DRAMA HOLLYWOOD HAS EVER SEEN.
>> CRIME DRAMA?
>> DAD WROTE A MOVIE?
>> IT'S CALLED "DALLAS CITY
BOUNCERS."
>> WHAT THE HELL IS "DALLAS CITY
BOUNCERS"?
>> OH GOD, NOT THIS STUPID
MOVIE.
>> OPEN ON WINDY DALLAS NIGHT.
LONE SAXOPHONE CRIES OUT IN THE
DISTANCE.
CAMERA REVEALS DETECTIVE
RICO TREMAINE, PLAYED BY THE
BROTHER FROM "DJANGO UNCHAINED,"
WHAT'S HIS NAME?
>> JAMIE FOXX.
>> YOU KNOW, THE MAIN BROTHER,
THE ONE THAT PLAYED RAY.
>> JAMIE FOXX.
>> HE WAS ON "THE JAMIE FOXX
SHOW."
YOU KNOW, I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
MAIN GUY.
>> JAMIE FOXX!
>> YOU KNOW, I CAN'T WITH THIS
MAN.
JUST FAST FORWARD PAST THIS
MOVIE IDEA, PLEASE.
>> YOU KNOW, WITH THE MONEY FROM
THE DVD SALES, YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PAY BACK JB SMOOVE ONCE
AND FOR ALL.
>> I THINK THAT'S THE SHOWER.
>> I THINK WE HAVE MORE TIME.
PRESS PLAY.
>>, WANT YOU KIDS TO
GIVE THIS IMPORTANT MESSAGE TO
YOUR MOTHER FOR ME.
>> NO, WHAT, HOLD ON NOW, I WANT
TO HEAR THIS.
>> BABY, WHEN I MET YOU, YOU
WERE THE SMARTEST, MOST
BEAUTIFUL GIRL AT THE DISCO.
AND I WAS JUST SOME LONELY
BACKUP SINGER FOR THE
COMMODORES.
I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU, I WAS
NEVER A BACKUP SINGER FOR THE
COMMODORES.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE YOUR FATHER
LIED TO ME.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE HE GAVE ME
EREC TILE DYSFUNCTION.
>> I HAVE SOMETHING VALUABLE IN
A TOP SECRET LOCATION.
BUT BEFORE THAT, LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT "DALLAS CITY DANCERS 2,
RICO'S REVENGE"
>> JUST FAST FORWARD.
>> WHAT'S HIS NAME?
HE SINGZ R&B TOO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
♪